the 737 max is the fastest selling plane
in Boeing's history but ever since it
was grounded in March its future has
been uncertain the crash of a lion air
jet in Indonesia last October with the
loss of a hundred and eighty nine lives
raised questions about the plane's
flight control systems when an Ethiopian
Airlines plane went down five months
later another 157 people died and
regulators ordered the planes be removed
from service since then Boeing's
continued production even though the
planes delivery to Airlines is frozen
with them grounded well into next year
the company's now called a temporary
halt to production suspending production
of a commercial aircraft is something
that has been very rarely done it truly
is an unprecedented decision they don't
have all the problems identified and
fixed yet and I think that they are wise
to consider pausing production for one
thing I don't know physically where they
can store these planes last week
relatives of some of those who died in
the crashes were at a congressional
hearing in Washington where a retired
Boeing production manager said he told
the company that factory conditions were
jeopardizing aircraft safety I formally
warned Boeing leadership in writing on
multiple occasions specifically once
before the lion air crashed and again
before the Ethiopian Airlines crash
about potential airplane risk due to the
unstable operating environment within
the factory those warnings were ignored
at the same hearing the head of the
Federal Aviation Administration refused
to set a timeline for the plane to
return to the skies when the 737 max has
returned to service it will be because
the safety issues have been addressed
and pilots have received all the
training they need to safely operate the
aircraft this process is not guided by a
calendar or schedule it's not clear how
the suspension will affect the 12,000
workers on the production line or the
financial implications the grounding of
the 737 max has already cost Boeing
billions of dollars
what price though safety and the lives
of those who've been lost
Greg Milam Sky News Los Angeles